[Musique]
monsieur Jéré bonjour Je t'interroge
aujourd'hui pour un site internet qui
s'appelle serw j'aurais aimé avoir ton
point de vue sur prisme les répercussion
de prisme sur la démocratie
Steller
alors les révélations sur l'affaire
prisme sont intéressantes à plus d'un
titre déjà parce qu'on a maintenant la
preuve
irréfutable de cette surveillance et de
son caractère massif et généralisé
pendant 10 ans on a collecté des preuves
des
témoignages on a eu des des informations
plus ou moins promente aujourd'hui c'est
un document marqué top secret/n for qui
est la preuve irréfutable ce chiffre de
97 milliards d'éléments d'information
juste pour le mois de mars
2013 pendant 10 ans s'est fait traiter
de
conspirationniste aujourd'hui on sait
que c'est la vérité mais ça c'est
l'élément essentiel pour pouvoir
commencer un débat public sur le sujet
de la surveillance de masse et espérer
éventuellement revenir en arrière sur
cette spirale ultra sécuritaire et
paranoïque impulsé par les États-Unis et
les marchands de canon à la suite du 11
septembre 2001 donc ça c'est le premier
élément le deuxème élément c'est qu'on a
maintenant la preuve irréfutable de la
participation des géants du web Google
Facebook Apple Skype et cetera dans
cette surveillance de masse et donc la
preuve une fois encore par A + B que
l'on ne peut pas faire confiance à ces
entreprises pour protéger sa vie privée
pour protéger ses données personnelles
et communication personnelle pour
protéger ses libertés fondamentales au
sens large quand bien même on
comprendrait l'intégralité des
conditions générales d'utilisation de
ces services au milieu il y a un gros
trou noir qui est le droit américain le
le FISA le forign intelligence
surveillance Act et la loi l'amendant en
2008 qui dit explicitement que lorsqu'il
s'agit de donner de citoyens non US
stocké sur des serveurs US les services
de renseignement peuvent y accéder
quelques soit le motif sans rien
demander à personne je je je je te
coupe est-ce que tu penses que les
législateurs français nos hommes
politiques sont suffisamment équipés
intellectuellement parlant ou
suffisamment formés pour comprendre ce
qui est en train de se jouer attends un
point avant ça parce qu'on oublie de le
rappeler quand on parle entre nous
pourquoi il est essentiel de protéger
notre vie privée ça sonne comme une
totologie pour ceux qui sont habitués à
ces concepts là il faut voir que la
protection de la vie privée est une une
liberté fondamentale ici en Europe
pourquoi c'est important parce que la
protection de la vie
privée implique la mise en œuvre
d'autres libertés sans protection de la
vie privée on ne peut pas efficacement
user des autres libertés qui sont par
exemple la liberté de de
rassemblement la liberté de
mouvement ou tout simplement la liberté
d'expression si vous savez qu'il y a
toujours quelqu'un par-dessus votre
épaule quand vous tapez vous allz pas
dire tiens le gouvernement fait de la
merde ou j'ai vu telle information qui
me semble suspecte ou si on allait
creuser dans le les les finances de tel
ou tel organisme la même façon nirit
peut-être pas une réunion d'un d'un
parti politique ou de quelque groupe que
ce soit si vous savez que le public ou
qui que ce soit d'autre puisse être au
courant donc la la protection de la vie
privée je dirais que c'est une liberté
fondamentale peut-être encore plus
fondamament que les autres à côté de la
liberté d'expression car toutes les deux
elles sont une composante essentielle
non seulement de la démocratie mais
aussi de l'exercice de toutes les autres
libertés et donc là on a un véritable
enjeu de société pour répondre à ta
question est-ce que les gouvernements
est-ce que les politiques sont équipés
pour comprendre cela je répondrai non
parce que nous-même on y arrive pas
personne n'est capable de comprendre le
le fonctionnement d'un
ordinateur
aujourd'hui déjà parce que les
ordinateurs qu'on a dans les poches avec
leur pu base bande sont complètement
fermés on n' pas accès aux
spécifications on peut donc pas les
contrôler il s'agit des puces
essentielles qui émettent et reçoivent
des flux ce soit de la voix ou des
données donc personne aujourd'hui n'est
en mesure de dire comment fonctionne un
ordinateur et quand bien même on
mettrait les millions d'euros
nécessaires à comprendre le
fonctionnement de ces puces d'une
seconde sur l'autre le fonctionnement
est susceptible de Chang donc on n'est
pas capable de comprendre comment
fonctionnent les ordinateurs de la même
façon qu'on n pas capable de comprendre
comment fonctionne internet on peut en
connaître des des bribes des éléments
chercher à en comprendre le plus
possible évidemment un objectif on peut
comprendre comment marche TCPIP comment
marche le routage BGP comment se font
les deals de bande passante et cetera
mais comprendre l'ensemble des
interactions technologiques et humaines
que l'on appelle Internet et quelque
chose qui par définition dépasse notre
entendement alors quand on voit des des
des conflits entre des intérêts divers
que ce soit des intérêts
industriels des intérêts politiques
ou l'intérêt général qu'on a d'un côté
les marchands de canon qui vont aller oh
là là terroriste et ca il faut mettre
ceci cela cela éventuellement emboîé
avec le pas emboîé par des associations
des organisations
pardon des institutions comme la NSA ou
l'armée ou des choses comme ça comment
peut-on imaginer que un politicien va
être en mesure de se dire non non
attendez l'intérêt général c'est la
défense des libertés fondamentales
liberté fondamentale c'est la défense de
la vie privée et là il y a un
conflit c'est impossible donc là on est
dans un rapport de force qui est par
nature politique et quand on on dit
politique hélas on est souvent un petit
peu en dehors de la rationalité où il
s'agit pas simplement de comprendre les
enjeux et d'appliquer les solutions qui
sembl optimale mais où il s'agit d'un
rapport de force et ce rapport de force
c'est citoyens du monde
entier face au marchands de canon et à
certains membres de l'administration US
certains membres de l'administration
dans les dans les gouvernements
européens donc c'est vraiment un rapport
de force
politique qui est assez mal engagé pour
nous
pourquoi parce que tout a été
parfaitement pensé et mise en œuvre il y
a ce bouquin de Naomi Klein qui
s'appelle de shot doctrine stratégie du
stratégie du ch où l'on explique très
bien comment utiliser des chocs
émotionnels dans l'opinion publique pour
imposer des mesures qui seraient sinon
injustifiable
inacceptable que cette stratégie est
parfaitement maîtrisée par les
communicquants qui conseille les
politiques et a été mise en œuvre
régulièrement par palier depuis le 11
septembre 2001 pour
solidifier un acquis de disposition
sécuritaire et que revenir en arrière va
être extrêmement difficile la la
situation économique se tend à l'échelle
mondiale les les peuples se révoltent
les ce qu'on a appelé les les printemps
de jasmin les printemps arabes tous les
éléments de langage pour décrire un
peuple qui se soulève parce qu'il a plus
rien à bouffer parce qu' un éat corrompu
à sa tête est-ce que tu penses pas que
les services de renseignement adossé un
pouvoir corrompu avec lobbyiste et tout
tout l'arsenal qui va avec est-ce que tu
penses pas que c'est une façon comme une
autre d'avoir une cavalerie sécuritaire
pour encadrer une population pour passer
un moment difficile de la mondialisation
économique c'està-dire faire du Data
Mining pour identifier des mouvements
contestataire bien sûr que si
surveillance égale contrôle on l'a vu
partout dans dans dans dans l'histoire
c'est c'est l'histoire de l'achetasie
c'est l'histoire des polices secrètes
dans tous les régimes autoritaires on
surveille les individus pas pour le
plaisir on les surveille pour mieux les
contrôler et ça c'est c'est un grand
classique le jour où tu entres en
politique tu commences à à te rebeller
tu commences à contester un petit peu
l'ordre établi le gouvernement et il y a
deux personnes qui frappe à ta porte qui
disent vous voulez vraiment qu'on expose
tel et tel et tel élément de votre vie
privée au public alors fermez votre
gueule c'est en général la première étap
avant de passer à la violence physique
donc ça va être compliqué de faire de la
politique et de porter des valeurs pour
notre génération il va être compliqué
d'entrer en politique pour qui que ce
soit oui on voit déjà aujourd'hui à
cette stade qui est sorti y a quelques
quelques jours qui montte qu'un jeune
sur 10 c'est déjà vu ref un boulot à
cause de son profil
facebook donc vous imaginez faire
refuser un boulot c'est quand même
quelque chose de de pas de pas très
exceptionnel c'est quelque chose de
banal alors imaginez quand un de ces
jeunes va essayer d'entrer en politique
alors d'une certaine façon je voudrais
pas me faire l'avocat des théories post
privacy parce que je pense que c'est de
la c'est la fouaise mais d'une certaine
façon dans 10 ans entrer en politique
quand on vous dira ouais mais vous avez
une relation extraconjugale ouais mais
vous avez fumé un pé ouais mais ceci et
cela ces chosesl seront beaucoup plus
accepté je pense à mesure que les gens
auront volontairement diffuser ce genre
d'information et en même temps ce que
l'on est en train de faire
c'est une espèce de réflexion globale
sur des valeurs qui sont universelles
quand je dis on c'est on les internets
quelque part sans chef sans leader sans
partie sans rien on voit d'un côté qu'il
y a les technologies qui libèrent qui
sont basées sur le partage de la
connaissance sur l'ouverture et sur
l'universalité de la potentialité de
participation de l'autre côté les
technologies qui contrôlent les
technologies qui surveillent qui sont
basées sur la centralisation et sur la
fermeture et les les les valeurs que
l'on pousse alors là je vais parler en
tant que porte-parole de la Quadrature
du Net quand on pousse ces valeurs de
défense des libertés fondamentales on
pousse ces valeurs de de du partage de
la connaissance c'est quelque chose qui
résonne euh au-delà des frontières
au-delà des limites entre les les partis
politiques et peut-être que cet objectif
là je pense que c'est un objectif de
société par son caractère universel
peut-être est quelque chose qui au bout
du compte sera plus plus fort et qui
saura s'imposer face à ce qui n'est au
bout du compte que la somme de d'intérêt
particulier d'intérêt sectoriel oui la
vente de de de canons enfin aujourd'hui
on vend plus des canons mais des armes
de surveillance massive oui c'est des
très gros contrats c'est des amessis
c'est des Blou et des machins comme ça
oui c'est des contrats énormes oui aux
États-Unis le budget de la défense c'est
je sais pas quel quel pourcentage
démesuré du du budget global ça
embbauche je sais pas combien de de
centaines de milliers d'individus et
cetera mais ça reste un intérêt
sectoriel un intérêt particulier nous ce
que l'on défend en face c'est un modèle
de société c'est l'intérêt général et
c'est des valeurs universelles qui sont
des valeurs démocratiques on on va
parler de valeur démocratique en France
les whistleblowers sont pas protégés ou
très peu mis à part fiscalement parlant
comme quand un gamin qui travaille à la
NSA ou qui travaille enarmée fait fuiter
aux États-Unis il se retrouve torturé
avec tout le manuel de la CIA qui peut
être appliqué sur lui privation
sensorielle et ces chosci comment la
France comment tu trouves le la position
de la France par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé je te prends le cas BR les manings
pourquoi a pas entendu la France à
l'international pour dire vous
torturez au nom de la liberté
euh le cas des des whistleblowers des
lanceurs d'alerte aux États-Unis est
extrêmement préoccupant l'administration
Obama a plus attaqué de whistle blowers
je crois que toutes les administrations
précédentes euh c'est pas seulement
Bradley Manning et le pauvre Edward
Snowden qui risque de de de de subir un
sort un sort similaire il y a jeln radak
il y a Thomas Drake il y a bill by il y
a tous ceux dont on n pas long temps pu
parler tous ceux sur qui la pression a
été efficace avant que l'information ne
fuite tous ceux qui n'ont pas pu aller
jusqu'à devenir
publ pour être protégé par cette cette
publicité
euh c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
préoccupant où on voit là le le le
rapport de force qui se dessine
autour de de de l'information on sait
que l'information c'est le pouvoir euh
et en même temps on constate que les
gouvernements et surtout le gouvernement
US utilise de plus en plus du secret
pour cacher des agissements qui sont
soit des des mensonges soit des des
crimes donc d'un côté il y a cette
inflation du secret et de l'autre des
citoyens qui ont entre les mains le
pouvoir de faire éclater la vérité on
voit que le gouvernement US est dans une
situation intenable il y a je crois 1,4
million de personnes aux États-Unis qui
sont habilités top secret et on a vu
avec l'affaire Snowden Snowden il bossit
pas pour la CIA mais pour BO Allen
Hamilton qui contractait pour la CIA on
se souvient des stratf des hbgar allez
Rin les PAL et cet c'est une myiade
c'est des centaines sinon des milliers
d'organisations privées qui partagent
ces formation donc tout contenu de
Google de Facebook et cetera avec
évidemment ce que ça implique pour là
pour le coup vraiment pour la sécurité
et la défense nationale parce que des
petits gars chez ces petites boîtes
machin qui peuvent faire faillite comme
ça du jour au lendemain sont 10 fois
plus susceptibles d'aller revendre des
truc des puissances étrangères que des
gens qui sont au cœur de de l'appareil
d'État et d'une et ensuite ces gens-là
sont plus enclin à à révéler ce qu'il
voient j'ose espérer que Edward Snowden
et et et d'autres vont inspirer des gens
au quatre coins du monde dans ce genre
d'institution que qu'ell soit publique
ou privée à révéler des informations
pour essayer d'endiguer cette inflation
du secret et cette dérive
technototalitaire euh est-ce que tu
crains pour ta
sécurité non parce que il y a des choses
auxquelles j'ai renoncé depuis longtemps
d'aller aux États-Unis euh déjà je vais
plus aux États-Unis enfin la petite
histoire l'avantdernière fois où j'y
suis allé juste avant la porte de mon
avion véritablement devant la porte de
mon avion trois agents du FBI sont venus
me poser des questions sur WikiLeaks il
voulaient des informations sur le
fonctionnement de wi je voulais me
transformer un informateur parce que je
suis amis avec Julian alors j'ai assz
bien résisté à leur pression il sont
allés jusqu'à me
faire à quoi j'ai dit écoutez je défends
des idées comme vous le savez donc ça
impliquealler en prison dit
arrêtez-moi il m'ont finalement laissé
repartir et c'est qu'après que j'ai
réalisé que l'ensemble de leur
intervention sur moi était complètement
illégal ils m'ont pas montré de plaque
ils m'ont pas donné leur nom ils m'ont
même pas laissé leur vraie adresse email
quand ils voulaient que je les contacte
une adresse bidon
àaho.com et ça montre l'état de
déliquessence euh des institutions
américaines et combien leur laisser euh
du pouvoir au-delà du contrôle citoyen
au-delà des des valeurs démocratiques
conduit à des résultats qui sont
complètement contraires aux valeurs de
la Constitution qui sont censé défendre
donc moi ma ma sécurité personnelle il y
a des choses auxquelles j'ai j'ai
renoncé de la même façon que à un moment
j'ai dû devenir une personne publique
entre guillemets en faisant le choix de
devenir porte-parole de quelque chose ça
veut dire que voilà je je fais des
interviews on prend en photo on me cite
quand je parle et des choses comme ça
donc c'est c'est renoncé une partie de
sa vie privée pour défendre une cause
mais je pense que de la même façon il y
a des trucs en terme de sécurité
où on peut pas pas passer son temps non
plus à régénérer des clés à faire des
fresh install à checker les fingerprint
des des différents bios des différentes
puces toute façon on pourrait pas parce
qu'on a pas les
outils donc il y a un moment où il faut
il faut renoncer je dis pas que j'ai
rien à cacher mais j'ai très peu de
secret et la plupart de ce que je fais
est public tu parle tu parles des
institutions j'ai encore de petit
questions mais j'aimerais juste rajouter
un truc làdessus c'est que je je me
compare certainement pas c'est ces
whistle blowers euh qui font des des des
actes d'un courage qui qui nous
dépassent tous on voit quand quand
Snowden parle il sait qu'il risque sa
vie qu' RRA peut-être plus jamais sa
maison sa famille et cetera qui met en
danger même sa famille en faisant ça
mais il
dit je dois le faire
euh je pense qu'on a tous au fond nous
cette cette étincelle euh de de de
liberté ce sens de de justice cette
humanité Bens qui peut nous pousser un
jour à dire d'un point de vue personnel
c'est vraiment pas une bonne idée mais
je dois le faire et je vais le faire
quand même et c'est ça le courage et
c'est ça que disait WikiLeaks en disant
courage cont le courage est contagieux
j'espère que c'est vrai je pense que
c'est la seule solution pour sortir de
cette situation deux petites questions
la première le rapport
jean-marieel qui est beaucoup chargé sur
les serveurs chinois alors les serveurs
Cisco nous poutrent depuis une trentaine
d'années qu'est-ce que tu en penses
est-ce que tu penses qu'il a manqué de
courage pour vasy enchaîne alors déjà je
l'ai pas lu la première à la dernière
page donc j'aurais bien du mal à en
parler en connaissance de
cause je pourrais
me rattacher à de précédents rapports
parlementaires comme le rapport labord
il y avait aussi un rapport Carayon sur
l'intelligence économique qui était
assez bien ficelé et qui déjà touchait
du doigt c'est même problématique que
faire confiance à des technologies
fermées ça n'est pas compatible avec la
démocratie et ça n'est pas compatible
avec tout simplement la maîtrise de ces
systèmes d'information donc que l'on
parle des logiciels fermés de Apple ou
Microsoft des spécifications de puces
fermé des routeurs Cisco ZTE ou Huawei
ou des baseband à l'intérieur des
téléphones ça c'est ça c'est une grosse
grosse question aussi je sais pas si
bokel a touché du doigt C là le problème
est le même le problème est le même que
on externalise la confiance dans le le
cœur de nos infrastructures de
communication à des entreprises qui
répondent à d'autres à d'autres
impératifs à d'autres objectifs que ceux
de défendre les les communications
personnelles ou les communications
sensibles et critiques des citoyens
français et des institutions en France
on on a un vrai problème d'un autre côté
je sais qu'on a un vivier de compétences
euh loin d'être ridicule par exemple
lany j'imagine qu'à Lancy ils doivent un
tout petit peu se poser la question des
ordinateurs de poche dit téléphone et de
leur rapport aux ondes communication
activation à distance ou des machin
comme
ça les travaux de Linc sur des
technologies qui concernent le grand
public devrai être par défaut publié en
logiciel libre ce qui manque ici c'est
une politique industrielle
qui viendrait articuler d'un côté la
recherche en sécurité informatique qui
se fait avec les moyens de l'État comme
àanc et de l'autre des objectifs de de
de politique publique qui sont ceux de
donner aux citoyens des outils leur
permettant de reprendre le contrôle de
leur information et de leur
communication à savoir logiciel libre
service décentralisé chiffrement point à
point il faudrait articuler tout ça
autour d'une politique industrielle un
peu cohérente je sais pas si si c'est à
Montebourg qu'il faut secouer les puces
ou directement à Jean-Marc h mais leur
dire e les coco lâchz quelques petits
millions de rien du tout pour aller
arroser des projets de logiciel libre
qui répondent à à ces critères là c'est
pas plus compliqué que ça les le les
talents sont déjà là les projets sont
déjà existants il suffit de il suffit
d'arroser il y a même pas à planter des
des graines dans le sol il suffit de de
d'arroser dernière question si tu avais
un conseil pour les générations futures
un conseil pour les jeunes qui nous
écoutent euh
parleleur laisse-leur une bouteille à la
mer sur Internet et donneele un conseil
c'est une vache de
responsabilité un apprendre à coder pour
apprendre comment fonctionnent les
ordinateurs et les systèmes
d'information en
général je pense que c'est à peu près
aussi indispensable que savoir lire
écrire et compter aujourd'hui et pas
coder dans des machins visuel Schtroumpf
mais faire de faire de l'algo parler
parler à la
machine de
de lire Stalman Moglen
lesessig
et trois en tirer les conclusions qui
sont que la défense des libertés c'est
pas quelque chose d'abstrait c'est pas
quelque
chose d'éloigné c'est encore moins
quelque chose sur lequel on a on a on a
pas prise mais c'est quelque chose de de
bien réel et sur lequel on a une
influence tous les jours par les choix
que l'on fait
et que la question au bout du compte
c'est quel monde on veut léguer à la
génération d'encore après et que
maintenant tout est entre leur mains
chérimerman
merci bien tes questions son vach c'est
bien
ouais